after almost two months of owning the
Tesla Model wire today we're talking
about three loves and one hate let's get
into it obviously Tesla has basic
autopilot enabled for free on all of its
vehicles and then you can upgrade to the
ten thousand dollar full self-driving
package as well in Australia that full
self-driving package doesn't have Autos
theater on city streets just yet so it
isn't worth it in my opinion however the
basic autopilot is something that is
phenomenal for somebody like me that
does a lot of road trips constantly
going three four five hundred kilometers
between cities the basic autopilot and
the lane assist is one of the best
features by far the amount of active
attention required and the amount of
fatigue that occurs during these long
road trips is quite vast however when
you are driving a Tesla Model wire or
any Tesla for that matter it is
significantly reduced by simply using
the basic autopilot feature for instance
the auto lane keep takes away the mental
fatigue of constantly going around
corners the speed assist as well as the
distance control again is something that
is really really useful now obviously
basic autopilot is available in hundreds
of cars around the world today but this
is one of the first cars that I've
actively enjoyed using it in and it is
something that is fine-tuned to a point
where it's actually somewhat trustworthy
even though it still does feel like a 15
year old learner driving the car at some
points as part of the driving experience
in an electric car not just a Tesla the
one pedal driving is something you
become rapidly accustomed to without
even realizing so for example I recently
drove back up to Perth which is a 450
kilometer trip one way in an ice car and
the Driving Experience just wasn't the
same there were so many times that I had
to mentally remember that I had to break
and not just let go of the accelerator
pedal so it is almost a weird strange
con that you have to get reaccustomed to
driving a normal car and braking whereas
in a Tesla and all electric cars you get
one pedal driving you simply press on
the accelerator to go and let go of the
accelerator to slow down unless you need
to brake suddenly and quickly you don't
really have to press the brake
whatsoever and like I said this is
something I became so accustomed to so
quickly that when going back to a
regular car it just takes a lot of
mental energy to go back to braking
where it's just so easy to drive one
pedal the last little thing I'll add in
the Driving Experience is a software
update as well as a general hardware
update previously there was a fixed
position on the screen where when you
turned your blinkers on it would show
what was next to you and who was next to
you now personally the way I used to
drive was my hands down at four and
eight and that always covered the bottom
right hand side of the screen for me
obviously being in a right hand driving
position now recently Tesla updated this
software to allow you to move the little
blinker strain wherever you wanted this
has been a game changer and it's so
simple now to drag the little screen up
to a position that isn't distracting and
isn't hidden so as part of the Driving
Experience the software updates that
make these General annoyances and
nuisances functional and reliable to all
drivers around the world is an amazing
feature moving on to the second love of
this vehicle and it is obviously the
Aesthetics all around starting with the
elephant in the room the white seats are
the most beautiful thing you can
purchase in a vehicle now I understand
the complexities of having white seats
and the fear of having white seeds
however they are incredibly easy to
clean they're incredibly easy to
maintain and overall it just makes your
vehicle look like this unique spaceship
it draws so much attention for good and
bad but it is something that brings
genuine Joy when you walk into a vehicle
and it is completely different from
anything you've ever owned in the past
I've always had leather seats or fabric
seats and they've always been a darker
tone even if we would have a tan seat it
kind of blends with the overall car and
the dark cabin itself it's a little bit
more Moody whereas is when you get into
a white Tesla Model y with white seats
white interior it is just so bright and
such a different Driving Experience that
it's so much more pleasurable to
actually getting this vehicle and drive
for prolonged periods of time something
that people actually like and dislike
about their inside of the Tesla Model Y
is the minimalistic interior for me
personally this is an absolute love
because there is nothing in the interior
it is so clean it is so simple and it is
so purposeful almost to a fault so the
glove box not having a button and having
to go through a touch screen is
definitely a pain but overall it Blends
in with the entire concept of vehicle as
an architect for me understanding form
follows function and purposeful design
is very very important so when you go
and buy a Tesla and there is just this
clean concept that's been maintained
throughout the entire design process is
very satisfying to see arguably yes it
is an extra 1500 rollers to get the
white seeds the minimalist package of
the white trim rather than the wood trim
but overall I believe it is worth it and
just like the white seeds package I
believe also the upgraded induction
Wheels on the model y are also worth it
I understand the wheels are again
another three thousand dollars to
upgrade from the standard Wheels to the
induction wheels and yes the ride height
is somewhat compromised because you have
bigger Wheels which is standard in any
vehicle but what you have to keep in
mind is this is a vehicle you approach
every single day this is a vehicle that
you look at every single day and it
becomes your pride and joy so for me it
actually brought me more joy to
understand that I'd be walking up to
this vehicle looking at it holistically
and going I love every part of this
vehicle whereas if I didn't buy the
wheels I would have just been thinking
ah you know I love the vehicle but I
hate these hubcaps I hate these wheels
and it just wouldn't have been the
perfect package the last love of this
video is very simple and very practical
the Tesla Model Y is incredibly
versatile and has an abundance of
storage now we debated the model 3 and
the model y against each other and
obviously they're near identical
Vehicles however the model y has
significantly more storage for whatever
it is you need if you're looking to go
on a camping trip if you're looking to
go on a family trip if you're looking to
go on a hiking or adventure trip you
have the freedom flexibility and
basically luxury to put as much as you
need into this vehicle in all sorts of
hidden spaces having the front is great
and versatile even though it's hardly
ever used because it is a manual frunk
it would have been great to have this as
a powered feature but there is
significant storage at the front which
most Vehicles don't have then in the
back you have this additional underfloor
storage as well as obviously the
incredibly large Boot and the powered
rear seats to allow them to fold down
and give you additional space if you
wanted to fit a bike in here or even
potentially some extremely long pieces
of Timber construction materials
whatever you needed you can most
definitely fit more than you can can do
in general Vehicles so overall between
the model 3 and the model y the storage
is such an amazing additional feature
that it makes it worth the extra money
now if you've made it this far in the
video make sure you consider smashing
that subscribe button and leaving a
comment down below for more great Tesla
content but we are about to get into the
one height of the Tesla Model Y and I
don't know if I'd call it range anxiety
or if I'd call it range frustration
because online the Tesla Model wire
predicts it will get about
455 kilometers of range at 100 charge it
predicts 435 kilometers of range however
when you go on nice long road trips
traveling to and from at about 110
kilometers an hour that range
substantially decreases now I don't know
what the rest of the world does when
they go out and purchase a new car but I
do some insane feasibility studies
compare it in extreme detail look at all
the servicing costs break it down to the
final Cent and obviously in my brain I
can considered 435 kilometers minus
maybe 10 for range inefficiencies you'd
still end up with a good 350 potentially
even 367 kilometers out of a single
charge which means you weren't spending
that much money on electricity for these
Longer Road troops what I've actually
figured out is if you're doing these
longer road trips comparing it to a very
efficient petrol powered car you're most
likely only saving half of your running
costs for the petrol versus the
electricity compared to my original
estimate of about one quarter total cost
for electricity compared to the petrol I
believe that the range anxiety and the
range frustration is still very real and
I definitely sway a lot more to range
frustration than range anxiety anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed the
video make sure you check out the
playlist the side of me for more gray
Tesla content if you love the video make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below but like always
see you next Monday